i've been journaling consistently for
the last five years
and it changed my life i'll compress
these five years into this one video so
you can get the same benefits and i will
show you eight practical journaling
exercises that help me stop
procrastinating achieve my goals much
faster and get me motivated within
minutes whenever i feel like giving up
let's start with the first one this one
got me through the darkest period of my
life and i learned this first exercise
from
arnold schwarzenegger after reading his
biography it's what he used to achieve
the impossible whether it's
the bodybuilding champion most
successful movie star
the governor of california before we
start and this is where i got the first
glimpse of
the one most life-changing lesson that i
learned from years of journaling which
i'll share at the very end of this video
he said
everything he achieved started with a
vision i had just been kicked out of
australia i had to leave my girlfriend
behind
and all i wanted was to get back there
and he described how he
visualized everything in vivid detail in
his mind
so that's what i did and i wrote down my
ideal life
in detail the business that i would have
that would give me freedom
having like-minded friends all over the
world traveling
during that time it gave me hope it gave
me drive it gave me
clarity and direction as well he said
when your vision is powerful enough
everything else falls into place how you
live your life your workouts what
friends you choose to hang out with how
you eat what you do for fun and that was
very true for me
soon after i met my buddy dennis
randomly somewhere we ended up
talking about business opportunities and
he told me about this thing and dove
right in
would that have happened if i wouldn't
have gotten clear on my vision
i don't know if you're in a bad place
you're feeling lost or you have no
motivation
this is for you this is where everything
starts if you don't have a vision for
your life then you won't end up anywhere
so let's call this one vision journaling
first ask yourself what would my ideal
life look like in three years or five
years
and note that i said ideal not realistic
if arnold did that he would
have a cow farm now the goal of this is
not to make a plan on how to achieve it
but to get you excited and also get you
to think bigger when i did this for the
first time i
actually wrote it as a diary entry from
start to finish of the day in
my ideal life this next one is for those
of you who say
i don't have time to plan out my entire
life every time i feel a bit unmotivated
so here's a quick version that i like to
do as well
this one within five minutes gets me
pumped and lots of fire inside of me to
get back to work
let's call it positive worry do you know
how when you worry
you completely blow things out of
proportion and catastrophize
for example you think what if i launch
my business and i lose all my money and
then i can't get a job
i have to move back in with my parents
all my friends make fun of me here we do
the same
but in the opposite direction just start
with what if
this next video is the one that will
finally pop views start piling in i get
subscribers i get more revenue i can
actually pay myself again i'm not
running dry anymore
plus then i can hire someone and we
become this media company that
has a huge family of really ambitious
people that are hungry for more in life
and i know i'm only five minutes away
from lighting a fire inside of me once i
had a vision i was driven
and i started my business things got
pretty overwhelming i had a hundred
things on my to-do list
and an infinite amount of things that i
could focus on to grow my business
and i was working all day but i felt
like i was making no progress
this next one is for productivity and
getting stuff done the kind where you
can do in two days what takes others a
week or really achieve in a year what
takes others three years
if you apply properly because things
changed for me once i heard about
gary keller and he's also the author of
the one thing and the question he would
always ask himself is
what's the one thing i can do that would
make everything else easier
or unnecessary when i applied it it
became crystal clear to me there's
really only
one thing that i had to focus on and
instead of worrying about some tactics
to
get customers to write better reviews or
some seo strategies i realized the most
important thing is that i just have
the best possible product for them
because if i did that everything else
became unnecessary if they liked my
product they would naturally write
better reviews i would get more sales
when i get more sales i rank better
which means more customers
more reviews more sales all if i just
focus on that one thing
instead of 100 different things it's so
easy to get seduced by
the 12 different tips that all help a
little bit but they all distract you
from that
really one really important thing and
since then i've been obsessed with this
laser focus and always finding the one
thing
that i need to focus on this one here is
from my buddy steve and he said
people think focus means saying yes to
the thing you've got to focus on but
that's not what it means at all it means
saying no to the 100 other things that
there are
here's how to do it first make a list of
all the things that come to mind that
you could do
to achieve your goal and then you want
to narrow that focus by asking the
focusing question what's the one thing i
can do
that will make everything else easier or
even unnecessary and make that thing
your absolute priority
and do nothing else until that one thing
is done this next one here was
huge for me i've mentioned it in a
couple of videos before and you guys
asked for it in the comments as well and
it absolutely
skyrocketed my business within 20
minutes it sounds so flashy but it's
true
in fact it was 15 minutes okay at first
my goal was just to make 3k per month by
the end of the year which was six months
away
but with this exercise i was able to map
out a plan that achieved a ten times
bigger goal
so it was a quite profitable activity
for me and a couple of months after the
deadline i had set i actually achieved
the thirty thousand dollars
patrick grove serial entrepreneur cool
guy did something similar he sat down at
a starbucks and journaled on the
question
how can i make 100 million dollars in 12
months
pretty ridiculous if you ask me then he
bought a small website listing cars for
sale
raised venture capital merged it with
multiple other platforms and 12 months
later the company
icar asia went public at a valuation of
100 million dollars so
what did patrick think well this kind of
worked out
do it again so he sat down to journal
about how can i make
one billion dollars in 24 months and
this time
he failed his company iflix the netflix
of asia
was valued at only 500 million after 24
months what a
loser it makes you think maybe there's
something behind it
maybe maybe why does it work though
because questions like that
challenge us to think bigger and then
oftentimes we see a possibility that we
didn't see before that was
been there all the time but we just
never opened up the possibility for that
and i heard brian lee talk about it
who's also an entrepreneur who's built
billion dollar companies
say that pursuing a 10 times bigger goal
is not necessarily 10 times harder it's
just
a different path it's just a different
set of actions and he was saying how he
had this little frozen yogurt store
while
also running this huge company and the
little store was actually giving him
more headaches and the big company was
building with hundreds of employees
and sometimes that path can be quite
obvious and completely possible
but we just never considered it and it
just shows up once we ask for it by the
way all these exercises are part of this
journal that i'm thinking about
launching as a product if you're
interested i'll just
put a link in the description here's how
to do the 10 times exercise
first write down your current realistic
goal
then multiply it by 10. of course don't
multiply by 10 if you want to lose 20
pounds because if i lost
200 pounds i'll look very different but
just magnify it to an absolute
dream scenario now careful this is where
people usually get uncomfortable
because they see this big goal and
they're like i have to achieve this and
they come up with all these stories and
excuses like
i can't do it because i have a bad knee
i don't have the money i don't have the
confidence i've never done something
like this before
we ask ourselves if someone else in the
same position as me
had achieved this goal what would they
have had to do in order to achieve it
see by doing that we strategically move
around all these excuses that we have
because it's someone else
and here you just brainstorm what are
the actions they had to take what are
the milestones they had to hit the
habits the skills the emotions the
relationships they have to build and i
know it's easy to say
i can't really come up with anything but
don't be think lazy keep digging
and once you have something that could
potentially work out is there anything
really stopping me from doing that after
i had a clear plan
to achieve that 10 times goal i was very
overwhelmed very stressed
so much could have gone wrong and and
this one is for you whenever
your mind is racing and i heard someone
call it
the mental windshield wipers which i
think is very accurate but i also like
the brain dump or
mental vomit because that's really what
it is you just start writing down
all the thoughts that you have
everything that comes up in your mind no
filter don't worry about grammar
unfiltered raw unorganized messy and
keep writing until everything that
worries you
is on paper then you can look at your
thoughts from a distance it's not a
storm that's raging in your mind anymore
it's just on paper right there for you
to look at and so many times when i feel
overwhelmed by all these things i have
to do they're just floating in my mind
like oh i have to script the next video
and then also all this thumbnail for the
next one also the call with one of my
subscribers is coming up and when i sit
down to write it out i realize
it's actually just these three items
that i just said i just thought it was
more but it's actually just this
and then i feel stupid every time now
this next one
is for you procrastinated out there
which is pretty much everyone to make a
long story short business wentz
i made it back to australia but my
business was a mess and i kept
procrastinating on building systems
and i wondered why do i really
procrastinate and the first answer that
pops up is
oh i'm just lazy and i just need to do
it and that's just
surface level bs because there's a much
deeper psychological cause that's making
you procrastinate because what if
it's completely normal and healthy to
procrastinate
what if you had perfect reasons to
procrastinate and if you knew what those
reasons were you could address them and
make it much easier to do that
challenging thing this exercise
goes to the root of your procrastination
speaking from experience
procrastination is always a sign that i
need more clarity and the three most
common reasons
are one you're not clear on how much
work is involved two
you're not clear on whether you're
capable of doing it or three
you're not clear on what the potential
outcome is it's usually one of these
three and think about it human beings
or any other species for that matter we
hate uncertainty
we don't want to move forward when we
have it but once we remove that
uncertainty
it becomes easier to move forward here's
how to do it when you're procrastinating
ask yourself why am i really
procrastinating and then you want to
write down
all the thoughts that pop up immediately
what is the first thing that comes up
and don't stop it well i just don't feel
like it and i'm lazy
why do you not feel like that keep
digging deeper what specifically makes
you not feel like it because the reasons
why you're procrastinating are hidden
behind these thoughts
once you create absolute clarity on why
it is that you're procrastinating
you can strategize on how to make it
easier now if you've seen the video
where i talk about my story
then you know what happened after
selling my business my girlfriend i
broke up
which then terminated my visa so i had
to leave again leave all my friends
which was devastating but with this one
i know i'm always just five minutes away
from feeling
great about my life no matter how
depressing or hopeless things seem
so let me show you the gratitude on
steroids exercise
i call it that because it's not just
where you write down what you're
grateful for
because it takes things to another level
think of something really bad
that happened in your life maybe you
lost someone or
you were diagnosed with an incurable
disease that you have to live with for
the rest of your life and think about
how happy you'd be if you could undo
that
and how you would give anything to make
it right with that in mind
contrast it with this how many things
are there that could have gone wrong
but they didn't and you could be
insanely happy
about being in your shoes now as an
example i just sit down and write
imagine imagine i lost my eyesight
and i could never see my loved ones
again i could never see a sunrise again
i could never
enjoy movies i would just see darkness
and think about all the people that
are suffering from blindness that would
do anything
to be in the position that i'm in right
now somebody's greatest dream
is your reality and that's a fact for
all of us if you're watching this
if all we do is change our perspective
and that's something that
is always in our control at any time and
this is the
single most important lesson that i've
learned from journaling we have control
about how we see things
how we feel the possibilities that show
up to us all you need
is a pen and a paper if you want to see
how i built my business
also using journaling then check out
this video here and i'll see you over
there